I've been working at British Council for
11 years now we offer from absolute
beginners all the way to advanced level
so whatever your level you can come here
to study
we offer general English courses and
business English courses if you want to
do an internationally recognised exam
than we do exam preparation courses
which will give you the best possible
preparation and we also have speaking
classes for those who only really want
to focus on improving their speaking
skills
in my classes I try and include a
balance of four skills listening and
speaking reading and writing a lot of
the time our students come out of the
French school system and so they've done
plenty of reading and writing what they
often need is to really work on their
spoken English and and their listening
skills as well I find the French are
much more comfortable with the written
word but then in terms of listening to
English and actually producing English
you know in speaking it's a different
challenge I'm learning English because
from my work is very important we ensure
that our students feel a sense of
progression during their courses here
right from the beginning they have a
level test and a consultation with a
teacher and they talk about where they
want to go and why they need to improve
their English in the first lesson we do
needs analysis where the classroom
teacher finds out what those needs are
and we'll tailor the course as much as
possible to the individual needs of
students in that group
it's important to focus on productive
skills it's not just about passive
knowledge and receptive skills and
things but actually being able to
produce English in classes it's amazing
written by teacher Rita OS of course
review program pathology conceal secures
immobilization foetidus Patiala Coeur
avec ma mesozoic emerado encore you see
everyone's body passive of a move
ethnicity